on vient d'écouter la ln génération me
demande c'est quoi vous la voiture sont
préférés de boys band vous c'était take
that le slow back for good
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
celui de gauche mais c'est un hobby
c'est le frère de serena
les treize fois je préfère maintenant
vous c'est quoi bon un alliage quoi la
canaille
mais pour septembre il va péter voilà il
ya le ballon qui est parti et salue
ballon trouver les ex d'isabelle morini
bosc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là c'était produit groupe allait acheter
produit par rappelle d'ailleurs on fait
partie chez lui l'ont fait on a fait
tout à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
oui vous avez bien et worlds apart
quoi
mais ma préférée des world à part ça
[Musique]
bonjour
deux fois moi je suis prêt
john solecki
normalement j'ai angoisses et kenny elle
déteste constance comme ça sur des world
apart
quand vous les effectifs étaient de tout
et ne vous quittiez parce que mon équipe
est comme moi ces chansons ouais ouais
ouais
est-ce que c'est par les mêmes raisons
je sais pas mais parce que non même là
on aime le monde on aime les apparts
vous aimez les ventes vous allez me dire
farmer va pas continuer l'émission rendu
maintenue en côte
non mais ça roule sans maxime par le
boys band le plus emblématique c'est les
to be free avec partir un jour
évidemment même dans ses chansons il
nous met un truc convient d'écouter
c'était to be free or not to be
ah oui c'est vrai ferment voilà ça c'est
beau comme le premier album que j'ai
acheté c'était les to be free 1997
ah ouais d'économie d'accord avec vos
petites économies
en fait il a une aura coûté voter parce
que tous s'en fout merci
[Musique]
kaka est capable de redonner le nom de
toute l'espagne à aa par 12h10 les
écuries alors jerry vie déclare huawei
malmy mails c'est bien parce que là il a
belle tu es en train de regarder sur la
tête d'honneur elle croit que c'est une
photo de vacances avec des piles coup et
vous c'est quoi alors le besoin alors
attendez les compagnons de la chanson
[Rires]
catherine déry commune les dinosaures
qui sévissent et lasserre louis triaud
ouais c'est vrai dans c'est quoi tu sais
la faire instruire j'adore m'amuser vous
en prenez mission en l'occurrence et les
m5
au marais
[Applaudissements]
la mise à jour mais si c'était exact
c'est pas vrai parce que si la venue des
semaines dans la cure web en tout cas
elle est bien rouge faut qu'ils
consultent même quand on donne un titre
pouvait les bonnes photos elle trouve un
petit salaire regretter après ce que
vous avez fait quelque chose sous peu
son butin est ce que le livre y sera en
version pas y arriver et il sait déjà
que les tickets on en parlait tout à
l'heure
mathieu mathieu delormeau est plein je
partais l'international nathan là on est
élu il avait plein des boys band que
j'aimais je partis à l'international
ouais parce qu'un petit blond qui tu es
très mignon c'est les backstreet boys
[Applaudissements]
et
m
tu vois du matin ya 53 ans tué à gaza
c'est le seul dossier sur dos un peu
comme j'étais au canada quoi bako koné
et alors ben non ça c'est ça c'est pas
celle des riches on lui disait fine en
effet parce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
entend c'est dedans moi j'entends alors
oui donc à paris disait qu'il en était
pas quoi lui disait qu'il n'aurait pas
tu vas donc en plus donc voila mais non
et donc non banon s'était pas fait du
coup j'avais pas durer c'est pas du
genre source qui connaît madame geraghty
alors moi c'est géraldine boukella temps
chinoise tout permis je n'aime pas du
tout je vais casser l'ambiance mais
j'aime pas du tout cette musique accord
trouve que c'est pour moi la soeur de
télé réalité de la musique c'est une
façon de la musique
gv asie et fais toi car si donc choisir
une vraie prendre à un groupe tout en
guitares et en poitrail viril
chaussettes noires et gipsy kings
[Rires]
[Musique]
georges jobé jobijoba physique aseptisé
là ils sont autant à bolton et contre
les gars soient soit ils sont très bons
aussi bien sûr
alors il y avait claude et cyril y'a pas
toi qui c'est à dire attentat on a vu
que des beaux gosses de peter pan
poursuit d'arrêt alors il ya yayi enora
malagré qu'il dit frérot jean-michel il
a une coupe de gendarmes c'est chaud
quand même
[Applaudissements]
ou à vous alors à moi j'aime bien les
les new kids on the block au bénin
[Musique]
évoquer les allécher squad mais jusque
là aucune fille au monde et ses
bénévoles
ben kingsley plus belle non c'est pour
isabelle est plus belle que toi pour moi
isa wamiz à visa
[Applaudissements]